more than 26 million Americans are under
a flash flood watched this morning as
severe weather grips the eastern US for
a fifth straight day a woman in Virginia
was killed by a falling tree and more
than a foot of rain has fallen in parts
of Maryland sections of Pennsylvania
have had about 10 inches since the
weekend DeMarco Morgan is in Hummelstown
Pennsylvania
DeMarco good morning John good morning
to you it's day 5 and you can still
barely make out this bridge right here
behind me that's covered in floodwaters
and we're also learning that the 90 year
old woman that was swept away by these
very same floodwaters the other night
the search for her will resume sometime
this morning the onslaught of heavy
downpours in Pennsylvania is leaving the
rain water with nowhere to go
residents in Northumberland County are
planning an exit strategy what I'm
worried about at 20 feet the roads under
water that way and the roads under water
that way so you got to get out or you're
not getting out floodwaters are washing
out huge chunks of roads and flooding
others leading to multiple closures
Baltimore County Maryland is having its
wettest July on record
emergency crews there have conducted
more than two dozen water rescues since
the heavy rain started Saturday
including three people stranded in high
water yesterday anytime you have a body
of water and you're not sure as the
bottom we don't recommend anyone walking
out this small bridge collapsed under
the force of the water at a central tree
came crashing down on a home in the town
of sparks inside we have water down
the Attic all the way down to here where
you can see the pocket and Charlotte
North Carolina
fire crews rescued employees of a
business after the creek behind their
building spilled over and filled to the
parking lot the storm is also being
blamed for bringing this massive tree
crashing down on a house in Virginia
killing a woman inside we haven't had
rain like this I don't think a really
long time and the National Weather
Service confirmed of the damage at this
High School in Fairfax County was from
an ef-0 tornado oh man we went from not
having enough range having way too much
the slit our Creek is already a major
flood stage and it's still rising as we
speak and by the time that it crests
today it will likely be at the third
highest point in its recorded history
now the rain is expected to continue
through the weekend and possibly into
next week Nora that's a lot of rain
DeMarco thank you